for those with no place to call home
it's hard to escape the blistering Heat
people like Sean Crowe who lost his job
and his apartment six weeks ago make
their way to cooling centers to grab
some water and relief it's getting
hotter it's getting a lot harder so this
this day room over here is really uh
resourceful I take advantage of it their
their resources and try to get myself
put together and get going in a
Direction so that's basically what I've
been doing for the past month and a half
or so because it gets really hot and
it's hard to kind of get up on your feet
especially if you don't have a car
exceeding 43 degrees the number of
people seeking help is on the rise
as our calls to emergency responders for
heat stroke our shelter is very close to
full about 99 capacity but we operate
with about a hundred beds uh in a
reserve that we that we can you know bed
mats that we can put on the floor for
emergencies and stuff like that so we've
started doing that we're not at complete
capacity yet but uh but we're over 500
which is our normal capacity for our for
the dorm temperatures topping 43 even 47
degrees are not unheard of here in
Nevada that but what is extremely
unusual and extremely dangerous for
those who don't have a home is the
duration of the Heat
it's a trend scene around the country
Phoenix Arizona surpassed 43 degrees for
19 days in a row beating a 49-year
record hits in Texas where nine prison
inmates have died from excessive Heat
this year families of the incarcerated
gathered at the State House to beg for
air-conditioned facilities now we don't
have nighttime cooling anymore that's
the that's the problem you know in a
prolonged Heat Wave it doesn't cool down
at night anymore now we don't go below
34 degree uh
Celsius
forecasters see little relief in sight
with these high temperatures expected to
continue at least another week Kristen
salumi Al Jazeera Clark County Nevada